[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir el desarrollo
de la copa américa y la eurocopa estos
son nuestros titulares aplico el campeón
en bélgica le ganó 1 a 0 a portugal y se
metió en los cuartos de final le bastó
un gol de torga en hazard ante ante el
defensor de la corona que mereció mejor
suerte además república checa-
sorprendió a países bajos
un duro examen para la campeona del
mundo francia va por el pase a los
cuartos de final ante la siempre difícil
suiza los de didier deschamps afrontan
el encuentro con varias bajas analizamos
que puede pasar
ecuador y perú se clasificaron a los
cuartos de final en la copa américa
la tricolor empató ante un brasil
alternativo y aprovechó el triunfo de la
blanquirroja sobre venezuela este lunes
se definen los cruces de la próxima
ronda
como cada jornada le damos la bienvenida
a nuestra lista sara castro directora
del diario va a ser colombia la
bienvenida como siempre un gusto estar
con ustedes federico empezamos con los
octavos de final de la eurocopa que
avanzan y este domingo hubo dos golpes
se fueron países bajos y el campeón
defensor portugal en el primer turno
república checa se impuso 2 a 0 a países
bajos la naranja se quedó con 10 en el
inicio del complemento por la expulsión
de 'matrix' del lic y seguro real en
aprovechó con los goles de thomas hobbes
y patrick chic luego bélgica se impuso
1-0 a portugal con un golazo de otorga
en hazard en el primer tiempo los
campeones dominaron el segundo tiempo y
merecieron llevarse algo más tenemos así
entonces en los primeros cruces
confirmados de los cuartos de final
bélgica italia el viernes en múnich y
república checa dinamarca el sábado en
bakú tras el partido roberto martínez el
destacó el triunfo belga una veloz
concentración nunca perdimos la
concentración tuvimos momentos difíciles
y nunca nos desviamos del foco cuando
portugal buscó la victoria hasta el
último segundo
estoy orgulloso esto me dio una enorme
satisfacción porque es lo que un equipo
ganador necesita
conocemos el talento y el buen fútbol
que podemos jugar pero creo que todos
los otros aspectos que se necesitan los
mostramos hoy
será difícil de leer este triunfo de
bélgica el gol de hazard llega en un
primer tiempo que se jugó al ritmo de
portugal en el segundo los de fernando
santos tuvieron sus ocasiones
bélgica termina perdiendo bajas área de
bruyne por lesión pero es un triunfo de
esos que se le exigen a los candidatos
bélica demostró que puede ser un equipo
práctico y eso es muy importante en
estos torneos que vimos en portugal a
veces tiene más nombres pero pareciera
que la idea de fernando santos limita
mucho la producción el juego del equipo
en el primer tiempo bélica también fue
muy conservador intentaba no perder
pelotas para no quedar mal posicionado
ante las transiciones de portugal y
luego en el 41 aparece este gol de
otorgan hazard que cambia el partido con
el partido porque portugal tiene que
rebelarse y empieza a lograrlo con la
entrada de bruno fernández o de joao
félix y sin duda merecían ir a la
prórroga intentaron de todas las maneras
por centímetros tuvieron dos opciones de
anotar de empatar el partido y que hizo
bélgica aguantar desde sus centrales
desde courtois y desde todo el bloque
defensivo que se armó que nos permitió
ver esto también otro de los registros
impresionante intentando jugar a la
contra guapeando contra todos
los defensas del equipo rival creo que
es un partido interesante por eso porque
vimos una bélgica que supo no imponerse
desde el dominio sino desde otro tipo de
juego y sus figuras ahí está el punto es
que pierda de bruijn el playmaker del
equipo y adelgazar que también lo había
mostrado confianza ha recibido dos
balones de espaldas en tanto intentó
regatear y creo que en el torneo es
fundamental también tener un gran estado
de forma y todos los jugadores en el
nivel para seguir compitiendo duramente
italia
más conforme con este este desarrollo en
el otro partido en república checa
siempre confiable en su rendimiento
termina venciendo a países bajos que se
queda con 10 y a partir de ahí se
determina desequilibrar un partido en el
que igualmente los chicos habían sido
mejores en el desarrollo se puede
considerar sorpresivo este triunfo fue
un gran trabajo táctico de república
checa es muy interesante de ver porque
siempre llevo al equipo de frank de boer
a jugar en sus condiciones en el primer
tiempo evidentemente países bajos
responde con los recursos que tiene
cuando les cerraron
intento buscar por fuera pero no pudo
rematar pero hasta ahí el partido
igualado luego la expulsión de del lic
cambia todo
evidentemente frank de boer intenta
jugar con dos líneas de cuatro que no
son suficientes y cuando república checa
tiene que ir a buscar lo hizo muy bien
tiene el goleador del torneo así que muy
buena respuesta ahí pero también estamos
hablando de otro tipo de fútbol europeo
y es muy interesante porque si uno ve
este equipo tiene la base del slavia
praga tiene un montón de trabajo de esos
equipos que compiten en la europa league
así que yo creo que va a seguir por lo
menos peleando haciendo partidos muy
interesantes en este torneo ya cruzamos
el ecuador de los octavos de final con
dos partidos este lunes en estos
momentos se juega en croacia de españa'
españa lo dio vuelta está ganando dos a
uno al equipo croata en copenhague más
tarde francia expone su candidatura ante
suiza los campeones del mundo enfrentan
un desafío exigente ante un equipo que
siempre es sólido como suiza es un duelo
con muchos capítulos y una leve ventaja
para francia nos vamos a atravesar a una
fase de grupos con apenas un triunfo le
acumulan siete partidos sin perder con
suiza y no cayeron en los cuatro juegos
disputados
en torneos grandes los helvéticos
clasificaron por cuarta vez seguida fase
eliminatoria de mundiales y eurocopas
pero siempre cayeron en ese primer
playoff
cabe destacar que francia no contará con
marcus thuram tomás lehman lucas digne
ni sus cunde todos lesionados escuchamos
a los entrenadores de ambos equipos
tengo mucho respeto por esta selección
de suiza y por el trabajo realizado por
mi colega pétkovic desde su llegada es
un equipo muy bueno
nicky jam tiene tantas opciones tantos
buenos jugadores para elegir seguramente
los principios del equipo permanezcan
igual y debemos prepararnos encontrar
nuestro sistema de juego e incrementar
nuestra asertividad y con todo respeto
por nuestro oponente intentaremos
avanzar en sufrir
'francia claramente es favorita en este
duelo pero suiza es un equipo que se
cierra bien y eso suele incomodar al
equipo de deshawn que podemos esperar
pero ya hablaba de un estilo de francia
que ha sido evidente durante todo el
torneo y que llevan los reflectores no a
su zona de ataque a mbappe benzéma
griezmann sino al mediocampo tiene los
dos mejores interiores del mundo cante y
pop back que han hecho una diferente
brutal porque son ese conector entre un
equipo que cede el control del partido y
conecta con esos grandes talentos que
tiene delante de suiza seguramente va a
ser un partido muy inteligente y tiene
una saca ya shaqiri que con esa conexión
seguramente intentarán hacer daño
partido interesante como todos los que
hemos visto en esta en estos octavos
cerramos de momento este capítulo de
eurocopa y pasamos a la copa américa
porque iban a quedar definidos son los
cuartos de final con el cierre del grupo
a argentina con messi como titular
buscará asegurar el primer puesto ante
la ya eliminada bolivia uruguay y
paraguay chocarán con el segundo puesto
en juego y también con evitar a brasil
hasta la final como meta chile esperanza
para saber si será tercero o cuarto en
los cuartos de final se esperan los
equipos del grupo b pero aseguró su pase
al vencer 1 a 0 a venezuela que quedó
eliminada ecuador aprovechó ese
resultado y logró un buen empate ante un
brasil plagado de suplentes esos
marcados les dejaron a colombia como
tercera tras igualar ante brasil esto
dijo gustavo alfaro seleccionador de
ecuador
yo digo nos da confianza obviamente para
enfrentar a cualquier rival yo lo que le
decía a los jugadores es que quería
clasificar
yo quería clasificar porque se lo
merecían porque habían jugado buenos
partidos y tienen un coraje de por más
que vengan golpes por más que nos
critiquen por más que nos cuestionen
ellos se ponen de pie poner el pecho y
van al frente y la verdad que yo me
siento yo personalmente me siento muy
orgulloso de estos jugadores en cierto
que brasil jugó con mayoría de suplentes
pero para ecuador es un buen envión
sobre todo ese rendimiento de segundo
tiempo que se pareció más ante el
comienzo de las eliminatorias que al de
los últimos partidos se perfila como un
rival difícil para los cuartos así que
es difícil hablar de suplentes en brasil
porque con todas las rotaciones que ha
hecho ti te digamos que visto han visto
muchas caras y luego el nivel de lo que
está en el banco también es altísimo
pero si uno se fija cuando no está
neymar el equipo planteaba algo
diferente
creo que lo de ecuador es muy importante
desde lo que decía el faro desde lo
anímico y sobre todo porque encontró una
manera primero de igualar la posesión
con brasil y luego a través de pelotas
largas y segundas pelotas que es cómo
llega el gol del empate
muy buen partido pues al mejor de la
zona y del torneo sin lugar a dudas el
jugador había mostrado buen fútbol pero
luego tiene esas falencias defensivas
que es lo que le ha costado en el torneo
y seguramente va a pelear creo que es un
premio para el faro y también un proceso
interesante que se está dando en
ecuador' bien en el otro encuentro perú
ratifica que se hace fuerte en las copas
américa mientras que venezuela se va con
sensaciones encontradas porque hizo más
de lo esperado teniendo en cuenta las
bajas y la crisis por el cob en 19 pero
pese a ello nunca termino de arriesgar
ayer para llevarse el resultado sí es
muy extraño porque a partir de todas las
dificultades que tuvo venezuela diría
que lo que se hizo en la copa es
bastante digno pero luego a partir de
esa dignidad tanto los hinchas como los
periodistas le han exigido más a peseiro
no un poco que desde esa comodidad no
logró mostrar un poquito más pero hay
que decir que no sólo las bajas del cobi
ya tenía a salomón rondón fuera a darwin
machis josef martínez es decir era
complicado armar este equipo y creo que
lo interesante va a ser verlo en una
eliminatoria una eliminatoria que
empieza a mostrar una evolución y a
venezuela como un candidato
a pelear esos cupos al mundial de perú
es verdad hace muy buenos torneos cortos
pero además a diferencia de peseiro que
no había podido trabajar mucho con este
equipo tiene un ricardo gareca que tiene
un proyecto y más allá de fichas que
esté ajustando nuevos nombres que esté
sumando pues evidentemente tiene un
trabajo mucho más largo y mucho más
proyectable a lo que quiere pues perú
para tener resultados en definitiva los
dos terminan sacando algunas
conclusiones positivas en diario de
copas ahora repasamos otras novedades
vinculadas a estos dos torneos
chilecito al delantero diego o valència
para la fase final de la copa américa el
goleador de la universidad cátolica
ocupa el lugar del defensor guillermo
maripán descartado por una lesión es
este su primer llamado a la selección
mayor luego de haber disputado partidos
en las elecciones juveniles
maison mount even chillwave podrían
regresar a inglaterra para el duelo de
octavos el de la eurocopa ante alemania
aunque se reincorporaron el domingo tras
superar el commit 19 gareth southgate no
descarta incluir los ya sea como
titulares o al menos ocupando un lugar
en el banco de los suplentes
salemma ya ultima los detalles para el
gran choque con inglaterra en wembley
recuperado thomas müller ingresaría por
leroy sane además el joachim löw evalúa
el posible ingreso de león gore tica en
lugar de incae gündogan en la mitad de
la cancha
bueno sara muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos nuevamente en diario de
copas y obviamente mañana estaremos
prendidos a toda la actividad con este
gran partido de alemania inglaterra y el
segundo choque de la jornada a ustedes
muchas gracias por acompañarnos sigan
con más en france24 in france 24 punto
com